sur place peut-être s'appelle encore il
ne viendra finalement pas cela devait
être le point d'orgue une déambulation
dans le quartier des grésillés pour
rassurer montré la présence de l'état
mais laurent nunez a fait faux bond
renforçant la colère et le sentiment
d'abandon des gens du quartier ministre
la peur de venir dans un quartier ça
prouve encore que la population elle
était légitime d'avorteurs tués ces
trois derniers jours
ça voudrait dire quoi qu'on en
insécurité totale cas plus une sécurité
même pour les ministres pourquoi ils ont
rien fait on aimerait bien avoir une
réponse du préfet de la police est
diaconale elle tend pourtant l'important
dispositif policier était en place la
voirie faisait peau neuve
pendant que les députés de la majorité
tenté de parlementer
moi je transmets la proposition du
ministre de rencontrer une délégation en
préfecture c'est assez classique comme
méthode souvent le préfet reçoit une
délégation quand il ya une manifestation
souvent les ministres viennent sur place
oui mais il est difficile à aimer liste
de parler un très grand groupe
laurent musnier aura donc écouter en
préfecture où ce matin plus de deux
heures à l'hôtel de police avec les
forces de l'ordre ou encore les élus eux
aussi remonté comme le maire de chéneaux
un sentiment de colère de colère de voir
que les appels répétés réitéré au
gouvernement au ministre de l'intérieur
ne sont ne sont pas entendus et qu'il
faut attendre il faut de tels événements
pour que nous ayons nous y ont peut-être
une réponse reste enfin le message
délivré devant les micros par le
secrétaire d'état le ton se veut ferme
il faut vraiment que les habitants de
dijon qui ont été je le comprends
traumatisés par ces faits mais
franchement je le comprends il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient bien en tête que
je suis venu rappeler ici un message de
fermeté et que nous allons tout mettre
en oeuvre pour confondre les auteurs et
les interpeller
ici en france la justice elle est rendue
par l'état nous sommes dans un état de
droit personne ne peut se faire justice
par lui-même enfin il a annoncé
l'arrivée ce soir de deux unités de
force mobile soit près de 150 gendarmes
qui seront présents autant de fois qu'il
le faudra